jean-christophe michelet champion du
monde de confiture depuis cet été a vu
sa notoriété populaire explosé en
quelques semaines
invité de la fête de la châtaigne à
éguzon pour présider le jury de concours
il a joué au jeu des questions réponses
pendant 48 heures je ne crois pas que ce
soit le fait d'être champions du monde
sont importants c'était important en
fait c'est j'espère vous pas de
maîtriser son sujet et professionnels
répondu jean-christophe michelet fait
partie de la race des gagnants dans une
autre vie il travaillait dans le
commerce international puis un jour il a
choisi de changer radicalement de vie il
y a quatre ans il a décidé de se
professionnaliser et de devenir
confiturier parce que les confitures
c'était une passion de jeunesse aux
championnats du monde vous avez un thème
imposé tous les ans cette année c'était
la pêche
alors on doit réaliser en fait deux
types de confiture une pêche
traditionnelle c'est-à-dire 100 % pêche
et ensuite une confiture insolite c'est
à dire pêche plus les ingrédients
entrant souhaite réaliser une confiture
de pêche de poivre de timides qu'un prof
qui vient du népal et de la foire du
discussions atteindre les sommets aussi
rapidement n'a rien changé dans sa
propre perception de son métier même
s'il reconnaît que ce titre l'aide
ça donne un peu de sérénité déjà fait
une reconnaissance malgré tout est
ensuite mais au niveau professionnel en
fait cette chanson
ça change des soûlards c'est à dire que
aujourd'hui on fait appel à moi pour
différentes créations
donc on peut on peut conduire au dessus
on peut se lâcher imaginer tout un tas
de choses alors qu'avant on était plus
limité on sur virginie
comment ça va revenu vivre ardente non
loin de châteauroux près de ses racines
familiales
il vient de nouer un partenariat
original avec une des fleuristes de la
ville quand j'ai appris qu'il était
champion du monde des confitures je t ai
contacté parce que pour moi je trouvais
que c'était une association de fleurs
avec ses confitures
voilà il fait des dégelées à base de
fleurs et je me suis dit pourquoi pas en
vendre à la boutique jean christophe est
comme ça dans le même temps ils
préparent les fêtes de fin d'année afin
que ses confitures fasse partie des
plats élaborés par les plus grands chefs
du monde